[Music]
morale engines is the latest Peter
Jackson epic that is based on the book
of the same name and directed by
Christian rivers the film's ending has a
lot to unpack from it and throughout
this video I'll be discussing everything
that you need to know about the movie
and the differences in it to its source
material there will of course be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want the
book or movie room for you then I highly
suggest that you turn it off now but
everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I ruin it so you don't
have to the movie follows Hester Shaw as
she attempts to assassinate London's
leader
Thaddeus Valentine sure once revenge for
Valentine killing her mother and for the
fact that he is attempting to take down
the wall using powerful technology
called Medusa Medusa is a quantum energy
blaster that has serious firepower and
was able to level the majority of the
world in an event known as the 60-minute
war in this battle America and Asia were
left uninhabitable after the majority of
them used their nuclear arms against
each other destroying themselves in the
process
Valentine wants to use Medusa to destroy
the shield wall protecting a stationary
society to gain their resources in the
film's finale however the plot is foiled
by Shaw and her ally Tom Nats worthy and
that doesn't mean that everything is
over Valentine is in fact revealed to be
Shores father and she was conceived
after her mother and Valentine ended up
in a relationship when working together
on aspects of Medusa Valentine deserted
his family in a mad dash for power after
gaining a position within London
Valentine killed Shaw's mother when
Shaw's mother found the computer brain
for Medusa and scarred Shaw in the
process at the end of the film Shaw
takes up Valentine atop another airship
where she is saved by Tom who sends
Valentine's crafts towards the ground
where it is crushed by London's treads
just before it stops killing the villain
in the process this drastically improves
the world in several ways and showcases
a bright future just on the horizon
London was initially a superpower but
with it now stripped away the world can
breathe a sigh of relief the movie
clearly has many metaphors for climate
change and environmentalist
we'll love seeing the eco-warriors win
in the end personally I believe that
Valentine short-sighted view can be seen
as similar to many of our world leaders
who refuse to admit that we are killing
the planet and that if we don't take
drastic measures to stop it then the
consequences will be severe it's a
strong message that showcases that we
must think of the greater good and not
our own selfish desires as they can
ultimately lead to our own destruction
London dismantles other cities in order
to thrive and to me this highlights how
evil the war for oil was as well as how
Greek can ultimately lead us down a dark
path whilst the book was published in
2001 its messages still sound strong
today
but Jackson & Co did change F a lot
about it in order to adapt it for the
screen the most noticeable change is
sure scar which in the source material
is described by Tom as too disfiguring
to even look at to me the film version
may be more audience friendly but it
slightly strips the character of the
strength that she possesses as in the
book she spends the majority of it
repulsing people the twist about
Valentine being Shores father is
actually told at the beginning and isn't
really used as a reveal as it's just
part of the plot I can see why they
switch the order for the screen now but
other major differences include
Catherine's death which is caused by
Ballantine in the book whereas in the
film she lives Morel engines the book is
followed by its sequel predators gold
and in that Tom and shore travel to
America and other part of the world that
were deemed uninhabited when making the
film Peter Jackson stated that he
actually prefers the sequels over mortal
engines so this definitely seems like an
avenue that could be travelled down
should interest in the film pick up
however as of this video the movie has
grossed a mere 22 million dollars of its
one hundred and fifty million dollar
budget so it seems unlikely personally
I'd love to see what else this universe
can offer or I highly doubt that we will
get much more beyond the booths there
already being published so what are your
thoughts on mortal engines did you enjoy
it and what would you hope to see in a
sequel comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and check out my breakdown of
this weekend's other big movie Aquaman
this is a channel for people who are mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to
this I've been definition you've been
the past and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]